Let's at the Joe Rogan experience.
So you have these fucks them sorts of roles,
lights on your head or just to help you navigate through the woods and to spot
predators.
Because of course,
if you're vulnerable,
you know,
and you see giant eyes ahead that are nine feet off the ground,
you're like,
oh fuck,
it's a bear.
Is she a two way street in?
It's like,
oh,
done the hun.
Yeah,
that happens.
I've had experiences where I've ran into predators in the wild,
uh,
particularly,
one time in Canada.
I ran into a grizzly bear and looking in the eyes,
and it wasn't even a big one.
It was like a six foot bear.
Wasn't huge,
but it looks right through you.
It looks right to you and say,
when you run into an animal that's killing shit every day and it looks at you,
there's,
I got demonic looking its eyes.
It's,
I've mean,
I've seen black bears before.
You don't see that look.
A grizzly bear,
which is,
you know,
more predatory.
They have a crazy look in her eyes.
It's really interesting.
I made eye contact with a couple of predators shock once in a shark cage on like
when I was doing that film,
Sarah Marshall that 10 years ago or went in a shark cage and right and they
lower you down and you see a shape a shark come towards it.
It's like lucky swimming through time.
It's like it's come from Navair it looks at you.
We'd like you think,
Oh fuck,
you know,
and like,
and I was terrified in that cage.
And like,
like Ed Norton was there and were the Olson,
they were on that island as well.
They were mates with people that are in the movie.
They go in the water outside of the cage.
Other other fucking mind that seems sane isn't it?
The shock was lit or and apparently is not a kind of shark that eats you,
but even the eye contact and it's fucking teeth.
I don't even look at it.
And then another thing I looked at once I was in a tiger sanctuary in India and
I like,
I didn't like the vehicle.
I was in a,
this is a,
I should,
I should have made clear that actually cause I ain't comfortable,
there's a better cheap over there.
So I got out of it to transition and my mate goes,
you more to get in a car in their mind it's fucking tiger over there.
And there was a tiger like only 10 foot away.
Uh,
might maybe I'm exaggerating.
Hold up 20 foot maximum.
Like if it was near and the way that that thing look,
I mean cause it's so beautiful as well.
The intensity of being looked at by that fucking creature have some powerful
shit you don't want eye contact without,
I don't want to look at something that's got like that.
You can't negotiate with the ICAN.
I feel like he'd look at me even with the Jujitsu,
like I've got that little moment where I go,
hey,
come on this Elle Russ.
Yeah,
we have a tiger.
He doesn't care about your mortgage.
Yeah,
neither does that.
Grizzly bear doesn't care.
They look through your kids.
Yeah.
They don't care.
No,
but that's all it's doing all day long.
It was killing me.
It's unbelievable.
Cause that's as true as everything we reflect on it.
Just to ask,
who gives a shit about your theories?
Don't
know what that is.
So their idea of what the wild is is really based on two things.
One,
their their actual love of animals.
They know,
right?
It's like dogs and cats.
So the animals that we know we,
we,
we have this connection with them.
So we think that the,
these are animals.
There's science projects,
man.
Those are not animals.
Real animals don't give a fuck about you.
They,
they,
they are in either indifferent to you or they're scared of you or they want to
eat you.
That's real animals.
The relationship that you have with a dog is like a child.
Like my dog is more like a child to me than he is like an animal.
I mean he's like my little friend that doesn't get to speak.
He doesn't talk.
But you know,
an animal in the wild is a competing organism.
They're competing amongst all the various organisms in whatever ecosystem
they're in.
And either they're at the top or if they're there somewhere below that.
And that's just how it goes in every deer is looking around cause there's cats
and the cats are slowly sneaking up on them every fucking day of the week.
And if you go in a place where there's deer,
you best believe there's going to be mountain lions there.
Cause that's how it operates.
And when you see that in the why,
it's so rare.
It's so rare to be around that.
But when you see that in the wild,
then you get a deeper understanding of what it means to be an animal.
What's horrific is factory farming.
What's perverse and disgusting is the way animals are treated when these lives,
these livestock companies pump these animals in these warehouses and make them
stand in their own shit all day and then abuse them.
And the horrific nature in which they're raising.
Yeah.
All that should be illegal ag gag laws.
Those laws were whistleblowers get arrested.
Those should be illegal.
Those are immoral.
They're letting people know what goes into your food and those people are being
punished for that.
All that shit is crazy.
They're being punished because it hurts business.
Yes.
Well it should fucking hurt business.
You're doing something that we all think is a moral,
that's how I feel about it.
I don't think there's anything wrong with,
even if they,
if,
if there should be standards and how cows are raised,
how chickens are raised,
let him live like actual cows.
That's beautiful.
And there's a way that they can do that where people like Chris Pratt from
guardians get great guy.
He has,
he raises sheep and he eats them and he even gives them out to people.
He has butchers that take care of it.
These sheep are treated like,
like they're loved,
they're not scared of people and then literally they get walked into this room.
They have no idea what's going to happen.
A bolt gets put on the top of their head,
Bang and the lights go out.
Now you could say that should never happen and those sheep should just live
forever.
Okay.
You could,
I can understand that argument.
Or You could say,
boy,
if you're going to eat meat and you're going to eat the meat of an animal,
that you know how it lived and there was no horrific moments in his life.
It just one day the lights went out.
That seems like the best,
most ethical way to do it.
Maybe even perhaps more ethical than hunting.
Yes.
Cause when I'm hunting an animal,
um,
it's,
you know,
it's out there in,
this is crazy state where it's always looking to get eaten.
These sheep have no idea that can be done.
They think that everybody's there,
buddy,
and then one day they die.
Yeah,
man,
I agree with that.
You know?
Yeah.
It's difficult to bring ethics to that.
That's clearly in my view,
a matter
of opinion.
Some people think that's okay,
but some people say the,
the turned around on me and say,
you could do that same like thought experiment with people.
Like,
why don't you just see people want like,
hey,
the person that had the perfect life,
he put a bolt in the top of their head and bang,
shut the lights out,
and then they turn into barbecue.
Look at,
yeah,
that's a very pronounced and vivid way.
But I would say that in a sense,
we're all like,
we're being commodified,
imprisoned in clothes.
He might like the very fact that a law has been made to prevent people regulate
in or revealing the truth around that.
Revealing it,
showing shows where the true bias of this system is.
Yeah.